[موسيقى]
مع احتدام السباق الرئاسي في الانتخابات
التركيه تبرز ورقه اللاجئين كملف يلوح به
المتنافسان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
يبدو وكانه يتراجع عن مواقفه حول اللاجئين
وبدا في الحديث بلغه تبدو اكثر صرامه
اردوغان وفي احدى المقابلات اكد انه وضع
خطه لاعاده اللاجئين السوريين الى ديارهم
واوضح انه قد تم بالفعل ارجاع 450 الفا
خلال الفتره الماضيه
تصريحات اردوغان تتناغم مع اقوال وزير
خارجيته حول الاعداد للقاءات قد تجري بين
الرئيس التركي ونظريه الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين والسوري بشار الاسد لمناقشه عوده
اللاجئين الى مناطق السيطره الحكومه
السوريه
لكن اردوغان وبحسب اتهامات طالت مواقفه
كان يظهر كمدافع عن اللاجئين ويطمئنهم في
وقت كان يعقد صفقات من اجل التخلص من
عبئهم
ومع اقتراب الجوله الثانيه يخطط اردوغان
ماليا لمسالتهم كي لا يتركهم ورقه قويه
بيد المعارضه التي جعلتهم احدى اهم
الاوراق التي تروجها لتنال كرسي الرئاسه
خاصه وان منافسه كمال كليتش دار اوغلو
اعلن انه ينوي فعليا توديعهم عاجلا وليس
اجلا بخطه اقصاها سنتان ترتفع حده الخطاب
القومي في تركيا مع اقتراب ساعه الحسم
ويبقى اللاجئون الورقه التي تتجاذبها
الاطراف كافه في سبيل الحصول على اصوات
المصرين على رحيلهم من تركيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات